this is really great news instagram just
totally canceled
pornhub three cheers for cancel culture
that's my kind of cancel culture baby
but no pornhub's a private corporation
and they have no they don't they don't
have any rights actually but no i don't
think it's fair that they show it's
totally fair get rid of them totally
send whoever runs pornhub
send that person away to an island far
far away from our country because they
are harming our country
instagram removed pornhub after mounting
evidence of alleged criminality
uh
that that has been stacking up against
pornhub
uh this according to the national center
on sexual exploitation
uh pornhub has recently been cancelled
by visa and mastercard
um
and that's that's because of this claim
of you know sexual trafficking and
child pornography and all sorts of stuff
on the platform
so it's good i'll take the win when i
can get it
but
the reason to cancel pornhub is not just
because of the child pornography and
it's not just because of the rape videos
and it's not just because of a lack of
consent the reason to cancel pornhub and
the reason why it would still be legal
today to cancel pornhub just based on
obscenity and the reason why we've had
laws against obscenity for our nation's
whole history even though lib insane
judges have really tried to weaken those
in recent decades
is because
pornhub and porn generally provides
nothing of value
it only it only deprives you of value
pornhub
simply preys on people's lusts and
addictions this is like any other kind
it's like the drug peddler around the
corner in the bad neighborhood
it's like the the mafia running the
numbers and the loan sharks and the
people
and even legal casinos that are preying
on people's addictions and if there are
not safeguards in place
as they're
as they're often or not when it comes to
drugs and as there are often or not when
it comes to gambling and as their 100
certainly are not when it comes to
online pornography if there aren't any
kinds of guardrails in place
it's it's just a a
vile path to destruction for the
individual and for a whole country we've
got to take it seriously i know that
sometimes the the pro-porn people they
say oh you're just being fuddy-duddy
you're being prudish come on man it's
all right it's not so bad naked ladies
on the internet whatever and they're
they're pretending that this is you know
been a
just a constant theme throughout human
history
it's not lust is a constant theme
prostitution is a constant theme
even
naked paintings and and photographs is a
constant theme
this kind of
it connected internet high-speed porn
everywhere all around the globe with no
that's completely brand new we've never
seen anything like that it's just over
the last 20 years and it's why my
mailbag is filled up every week with
young men and actually young women
somewhat often as well writing in about
how porn has ruined their lives and they
were exposed to it when they were little
kids and you just get just get rid of it
that's it it doesn't provide value when
i go out if i sell the leftist tears
tumbler which i do if i'm selling the
leftist year's tumblr i am selling your
product you have to pay whatever it
costs for the leftisters tumbler and
we've now had an exchange of value
because now you you know i get your
money and you get a vessel to collect
all the leftist tears which is
everywhere otherwise you know it could
you'd get too much salt on your property
and you wouldn't be able to grow
tomatoes anymore that's that's why you
need the leftist ears tumbler and then
you can direct it down your gaulet and
enjoy those those leftist years so we're
we're each getting something of value
when it comes to something like
porn
or heroin or whatever or any sort of
vice you're not getting
any sort of real
deep vice and there's it's just gravely
sinful in and of itself
you're not getting anything of value and
so it's wrong it's wrong it's wrong to
be involved in that anyway the models
are a problem too okay and the
advertisers are a problem too and the
credit card companies are a problem too
and instagram which gives porn have a
platform that's a problem too and
they're beginning to realize that and
they're going to cancel it and that's
great we should cheer on that canceled
culture
you know how big a problem this is it's
even affecting celebrities
it's even maybe that shouldn't be so
surprising but to my mind it often is
when people who are super rich and
famous and have all the resources in the
world when they fall prey to the same
sorts of problems and addictions and
vices that ordinary people fall prey to
it's just a reminder that this kind of
how potent this is you can't buy your
way out of certain addictions very often
it's the the celebrities who most easily
fall prey to addictions drinking and
drugs and promiscuity and all of that
well kanye is just saying that too kanye
just gave an interview he said that
pornography ruined his family it was a
little vague on how pornography did that
he says
he was uh
writing on instagram about his daughters
and sort of to his daughters
don't let chris jenner you know the
mother or the matriarch of the
kardashian family
don't let her make you do playboy like
she made kylie and kim do hollywood is a
giant brothel pornography destroyed my
family i deal with the addiction
instagram promotes it not going to let
it happen to northea in chicago
my kids will not do playboy and sex
tapes he then tells kim kardashian tell
your clinton friends to come get me i'm
here
so you say it's a little unclear here or
maybe he's just saying both things
because he's saying on the one hand
pornography destroyed my family because
i'm addicted to pornography right he's
saying i've dealt with the addiction but
on the other hand he's saying
pornography destroyed my family because
my wife was was pressured into
pornography by her own mother the whole
family was pressured to be i mean that's
ultimately
what got kim kardashian famous
was becoming a porn star and then she's
done other things since then but that
was her big explosion into fame and was
arranged by her mother apparently and
that's sick that's really really sick
and he's saying you're not going to make
my daughters do that
just like your mother made you do that
don't you dare do it
it's awful and and kanye's speaking not
just as a father wants to protect his
kids he's speaking as someone who has
dealt with an addiction to pornography
he's saying i've seen this issue from
all sides of it all of which is to say
and he gets to instagram specifically he
says
instagram's promoting it well not
anymore really really good stuff kanye
also made a really good point this is a
little tangential but i loved it so much
kanye said that the his the schools that
his kids are possibly attending
are really stupid and live and teaching
all sorts of crazy stuff he says they
teach black kids kwanzaa at sierra
canyon school
what the f is kwanza and who made that
bs up
everyone lives in la for the check
anyway so no one really cares about
their children being indoctrinated spot
on and now you know i give kanye a lot
of credit and i think that he's got a
more insightful view into politics than
99 of people including the vast majority
of republicans
he does in his own kind of weird kanye
way he does and he's really insightful
here too and he says who the f made this
bs up about kwanzaa what are these so
cal crazy teachers teaching this about
kwanzaa he's right
it was a lunatic southern california
teacher who invented it in the first
place
ron everett in 1966
who restyled himself melania karenga but
his real name is ron everett he invented
kwanzaa when he was a teacher at cal
state north beach or cal state long
beach rather and then a little later on
he was arrested for imprisoning and
torturing women
had a pretty bad history but yeah
it's true it all comes from these
bizarre wackos in gamora by the sea
known as southern california right now
head on over to
bambi.com and type in michael knowles
under podcast when you sign up when you
are running a business you will get hit
with all kinds of strange scenarios
let's say an employee not showing up to
work on time maybe a wrongful
termination suit one complaint can
destroy your entire company the problem
is hr managers are expensive they can
easily cost over eighty thousand dollars
per year but with bambi you get access
to your own dedicated hr manager
starting at just 99
a month all of bambi's hr managers are
based in the united states they can
support the nuances across all 50 states
your manager is available by phone email
and real-time chat to help you
effortlessly run employee onboardings
and terminations encourage good
performance and make sure your business
stays compliant with ever-changing hr
regulations with bambi's hr autopilot
you can automate the most important hr
practices such as setting policies
training and feedback in fact bambi
clients are four times less likely to
have a complaint filed against them go
to bambi.com right now type michael
knowles under podcast when you sign up
that is
b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com bambi.com type in michael
knowles
i'm so glad you like that clip now what
hold up
huh
you gotta ring that bell subscribe get
all the notifications that way we'll not
only have we hit a million subscribers
we're going to hit 1 trillion make sure
you do it now we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you